come here you guys we're going to film a
video come here come here
come
up all the way
okay you can have these first
hello everybody how's it going my name
is moyuko and welcome back to my channel
i've got two very special guests here
today
my dogs kona and ellie
so i realized recently that i have a lot
of people around me who were getting
dogs and then i also realized i know a
lot about dogs because i've learned them
over the last how old are you kona seven
years so today i want to make a video
about dog ownership because i feel like
that's a thing that a lot of people
consider in their 20s and 30s and beyond
so i went on instagram a couple weeks
ago and i asked y'all for some questions
about having dogs i've kind of divided
this video into two parts so the first
part is about getting a dog adopting a
dog that whole process and then part two
is about like actually owning a dog and
all the lifestyle changes and so quick
background about me and dogs in general
so i grew up with a dog i got my very
first dog when i was seven years old he
was a beagle named pepper we loved him
so much i grew up with him all my life
he you know saw me through elementary
middle high school and college and
beyond and so because i grew up around
dogs one of my dreams was to own a dog
post graduation we adopted yukona in
november of 2014 i graduated in
august of no july of 2014 so i got you
four months after i graduated so kona
was like my dream dog
excuse you miss off
off yes good girl as i was saying i was
living with scott at the time already we
lived in a tiny 500 square foot
apartment with kona and then a year
later we moved to the bay area where we
lived in a 1500 square foot townhouse
for a while which didn't have a yard but
we lived with him for that whole time we
also go to cat benny at that time and
then in 2020 we moved to the current
house that we're in has a really big
yard and then at the end of 2020 in
november we got ellie yeah i've lived
with dogs like my whole adult life life
is just very weird without dogs around
me so before i move on napping ellie and
i want to thank the sponsor of today's
video helix sleep they're a company that
creates premium mattresses customized to
fit your needs delivered right to your
door they've got a sleep quiz that
matches the perfect mattress to your
body type and your sleep preferences
i've actually got two helix sleep
mattresses at home both of which are the
dusk lux and i like them so much that i
recently gifted one to my friend alex
this is a queen size
midnight lux first impression the
mattress is
it's so bouncy for a foam mattress i
think it's actually hybrid but by far
the comfiest one i've ever slept on i
don't even want to get up in the morning
and his roommate actually has decided to
also get a helix sleep mattress after
laying on his helix delivers your
mattress right to your door which is
rolled up in a box and it's super easy
to set up and they have free shipping in
the u.s they include a 10-year warranty
and they offer financing options and
flexible payment plans they've also got
a 100 night sleep child to make sure
that you really love the mattress so
visit
helixsleep.comhellomyugo to get up to
200 off your helix mattress plus two
free pillows thank you again helix for
sponsoring and now let's get back to the
video okay so part one about getting a
dog one of the first things that i want
to talk about is where to get your dog
because i think this is one of the very
first decision points that i really want
to talk about i'm kind of passionate
about this topic and that's really about
getting a dog either from a rescue or a
breeder in southern california i think
in all of southern california but
definitely in san diego county pet shops
are like not a thing here because pet
shops tend to kind of facilitate what we
call backyard breeders and puppy mills
which create like really inhumane
unethical really dirty not great
environments for puppies to be born into
so if you are gonna go to puffy mill
like ask them about their practices and
where they get their dogs i recommend
going through a certified breeder or a
rescue instead so if you're going to go
through a breeder then you're probably
choosing a certain type of breed that
you're going to go for just check to
make sure that they're certified and
they're not like inbreeding their dogs
too much and stuff because that can
cause health problems i've actually
never gone through a breeder so that's
all i can really say on the topic but
the other side of it is the rescue so
the first question that i want to answer
is the is it hard to take on a rescue
and i think it really depends it can be
for me it hasn't been at all these two
have been just angels like so good like
they're such good dogs but i think
there's a couple things to think about
so rescues typically rescue dogs from
either dog shelters or sometimes like
hoarding situations sometimes they're
just found on the street and they're
taking into foster care for a few weeks
or a few months depending on what their
health issues are and then they're
adopted out to a family there's lots of
different kinds of rescues out there so
the first thing to think about when
looking at dogs on rescue websites so
you can either go to the website itself
or look at them on pet finder is that
the breed labels are always going to be
wrong and that's because certain breeds
have stigmas associated to them it's
like german shepherds pit bulls
dobermans all are kind of have this like
scary really aggressive kind of vibe
because of that most dogs are going to
be labeled as like labrador retriever
mix or like pointer mix or
golden retriever mix it's kind of it's
pretty honestly pretty discriminatory
and the other thing about those breeds
is like yes some of them are definitely
bred to be guard dogs and be aggressive
and stuff like that but i believe that a
lot of it is based on um yes maybe part
of it is their energy level and
temperament but a big really huge part
of it is how the owner treats that dog
and so don't let the breed or like the
shape of the head or anything scare you
so if you're not from a rescue the thing
that they really want to make sure is
that that dog is not going to come back
to the rescue like the dog's going to be
in a happy place and so one of the
things that they usually do is like a
meet-and-greet where you get to meet the
dog before you say yes i want to adopt
them this happens after you send the
application and they're like yeah this
is a good person let's let's set up the
meet and greet and so we did meet and
greets for both ellie and kona and
honestly we got really lucky because we
didn't really know what we were looking
for especially for kona because he was
her first and both of them have very
chilled temperaments for ellie when we
were looking at her application like her
dog detailed description it said that
she was really chill and we were like
cool we like chill if you're chill as a
puppy you're probably chill as an adult
but if we were to kind of adopt another
dog i think we would look for those key
words again that they're like mild
tempered um they're also very responsive
like you want a dog that's really easy
to train and quick note if you're gonna
go see a puppy they're likely gonna be
hyper and playful because all puppies
are they're they're like little toddlers
and babies they have so much energy so
yeah i don't have like a hard and fast
rule for this whole thing about like how
do you know if you're compatible with a
rescue dog honestly you just have to
meet them and it's like a vibe check so
just go with your gut honestly i don't
have great advice for this part okay and
the other kind of big psa that i want to
give when it comes to choosing a dog is
you don't get a dog just because it's
the cutest dog dogs are 10-year
commitments and so you really want to
make sure that you are compatible with
this dog i know a lot of friends who've
gotten dogs just because they're cute
and then they realize the dog is the
devil and they can't take care of him
anymore and really i think one thought
exercise you could have is yes the dog
is cute but could you live with this dog
and take care of them not just for a
week but like every single day for a
month weekends and holidays included
because you were going to be that dog's
parent every single day the next part
that i want to talk about is the cost so
in 2021 all of my pet expenses between
kona and ellie probably a little bit of
benny but she really is super low
maintenance it totaled to 4982.74
and that total is kind of divided into
two different buckets one is medical
related and so we take them to yearly
checkups to the vet to make sure that
they're healthy and we also get
medication for them for flea ticket and
heartworm which is just maintenance to
make sure that they don't get diseases
the vet expenses were 2062.62
so those are all the vet expenses i will
say that probably like 1500 of that was
ellie because she just has a lot of
allergies and also these two had a lot
of like ear infections last year so
likely if your dog is healthy and
doesn't have huge medical issues it's
going to be less than that and then the
other part of it is like the foods
treats and toys we get them like really
high quality food we always have treats
on hand and they have hella toys and so
we spent two thousand nine hundred and
twenty dollars and twelve cents on all
of that last year now let's go on to
part two which is about taking care of a
dog the first question that i want to
answer is from maddie and she says how
did you manage having dogs schedule wise
and working nine to five which is a
great question because yes dogs require
a lifestyle change they need a lot more
care than other animals we're not
constantly working every single minute
of the eight hour work day and so the
times that we need breaks we tend to
just like hang out with the dogs or do
stuff but our dogs are really chill they
just demand to walk in the morning and
then they kind of just like hang out and
nap for most of the day at around four
or five o'clock they need another walk
and so we take them out and those walks
can be anywhere from 10 to 30 minutes i
actually really appreciate that dogs
kind of like help me take me out of my
whole work routine like especially when
i was really busy with work when i was
living in the bay it was really
grounding to be like okay but i also
need to take care of this animal so yeah
most dog owners have some sort of
routine with their dogs and that's
something that you establish within the
first year or two and it really depends
on your lifestyle and the dog's kind of
personality so in terms of like getting
a dog that matches your lifestyle the
next question is all about kind of can
you have a dog living in an apartment in
this tiny apartment and the answer is
yes of course you can but again it
really depends on your energy levels and
the dog's energy levels and what you can
do to help manage that dog's energy
level so if you get a dog that's high
energy they're likely gonna need a lot
of exercise so if you get like a vicila
or a beagle or a corgi then they're just
gonna need a lot of stimulation and
they're gonna need to like run for like
two hours of the whole day sort of thing
our dogs are very lucky they don't need
a whole lot of exercise or they don't
get like antsy and rip up furniture and
misbehave if they don't get that level
of exercise but when kona was a puppy he
definitely had a lot of energy and like
i said we lived in a tiny 500 square
foot apartment but what really worked
for us was that we had two dog parks
within our apartment complex that we
could bring into for a daily puppy
playtime where he would like roughhouse
and play with all of our neighbor dogs
so if you are going to live in an
apartment just make sure that there's a
way for the dog to get their energy out
whether on walks or playtime or
running or whatever else so the next big
lifestyle change that you might
encounter in having a dog is about this
how do you travel with or without them
now yes traveling is one of the tricky
parts about dogs because you can't just
leave them at home like you can with
cats cats you can just kind of like
leave them at home with food and water
in a litter box for like a week so we've
been really lucky because when we lived
in the bay scott's parents took care of
our dogs when we were away and then now
that we're in san diego we have a lot of
dog friends where we like mutually watch
each other's dogs when anyone goes on
vacation and that's really worked out
for us but i think a lot of it is just
coming down to can you find someone you
can trust to watch your dogs alright
next big lifestyle change this is
literally probably one of the most
disruptive intense parts is about how do
you deal with a dog's poo and pee this
is the thing that i think is actually
kind of the hardest especially when
you're taking care of a puppy because
puppies are not potty trained they don't
come potty trained but you have to teach
them so with kona we adopted him at 10
weeks and it honestly took three or four
months to get him fully potty trained it
was like a gradual thing i've had being
like potty pads in our house and then
also setting up like a pen for him so
that no matter what he would always pee
on the potty pads like he could do no
wrong setting up that association to
like i'm going to go potty on the potty
pads and as soon as that association
clicked then we gave him more and more
room so that he still had that
association but he knew exactly where to
go to do his business then eventually we
moved the potty pads to our like patio
which then kind of gave him the idea of
like oh outside is where i go to potty
and then we just kind of went for it and
took away the potty pads totally uh and
then he was potty trained but it took a
very long time i just remember those
first like few months i was like i feel
like i'm living in a stye of poo and pee
ellie on the other hand we got her when
she was six months old and so she was a
little bit she had more like bladder
control and so it was a little easier to
potty train her she was also very
responsive so i think it maybe took like
a month maybe to get her used to going
outside and for that we we did use potty
pads but really what we did was every
hour we would take her out and if she
partied outside we would reward her for
it so we did kind of two very different
methods for our dogs and we did
something that works for both of them
just based on what they were used to
prior and their age
next question is about how do you deal
with shedding which yeah dog shed
i don't honestly mind it because my
beagle that i grew up with shed so i'm
like used to it as like a lifestyle
thing it's okay that there's dog hair in
places like my hair is also in places
but yeah it's it's a lot and so some of
the things that we've done to help us is
to number one get a really good vacuum
number two get a really good wet vacuum
and number three get stuff that you can
machine wash okay the next big question
that i got a bunch of times was about
training which all of these things about
lifestyle changes and stuff like can
really all be managed and mitigated with
proper training and then the second kind
of meta question that i got with this is
like should i put my dog in training is
it actually necessary i'm gonna say if
this is your first time taking care of a
dog then absolutely yes it's really
helpful to put your dog in training not
to train your dog but to train yourself
to learn how to train a dog because the
most important thing is to set up a way
to communicate between yourself and the
dog like they're not people so they
don't understand words inherently like
we do and so it's a lot about learning
how to cue them how to motivate them how
to reward them those are all things that
you learn in a training class so even
though i grew up with a dog i still went
to training class with kona every week
for about like three months when we
first got him and it was super helpful
because i learned things like shaping
and positive reinforcement but after
that i got a hang of like what it takes
to train dogs typically i use sort of
the positive reinforcement way of doing
things i never like hit my dogs like
none of that there's a lot of really
great youtube channels actually out
there on how you can train your dog to
do certain tricks or to curb certain
behaviors if you're thinking about
getting a corgi or shiba inu because
those two are really popular dogs that
need honestly a lot of training then
definitely look into it okay so the last
part is really just about general advice
that i have for all of you who are
thinking about getting dogs so having
dogs is definitely one of the most
rewarding and most amazing things like i
honestly think of my dogs as like my
children and i can't imagine a life
without them i have such a strong bond
with both of them genuinely we don't
deserve dogs i love dogs but again i
will caveat this i think one realistic
way to think about whether you're ready
to have dogs is the first two years
especially if you're getting a puppy
maybe a little less so if you're getting
an older dog it's going to require a lot
of patience as you learn what your dog's
needs are and they adjust to your
lifestyle and it's a long-term
commitment dogs live anywhere from eight
to 16 years and so just really think
about whether you can commit to that
time just know that like there's no
one right way to do things but it is
important to know that like
you it takes a lot of patience but if
you work on it it can work but these are
just some of the main lessons that i
want to talk about to dog ownership if
you have any questions leave them in the
comments down below i really like
talking about dogs i can recommend like
dog treats dog toys big chunk of my life
is dogs gonna shake
good boy kind of big
yes good boy good job give me 10.
yes good girl
good job here you go good job guys
you did it
thanks for being in my video youtube
[Music]